zendaya reveals her favorite quality
about tom holland and it's the sweetest
thing you'll hear all day well thank you
the 25 year old actress covers in
style's best dressed issue and inside
the mag she's opening up about her
spider-man co-star and rumored flame i
just feel very lucky quote in an actor
way i appreciate that he really loves
being spider-man it's a lot of pressure
you take on the role of a superhero
wherever you go to the little kid who
walks by you are spider-man i think he
handled that so well you ready yeah
you're gonna love this zendaya adds that
tom is a perfectionist at work something
she says she witnessed firsthand quote
it was so cool to see how he cares so
much about his work and making it right
i watched him do a fight scene all day
which is exhausting he'd do a move come
back to the monitors watch it and say i
can do that better i'd be like dude you
got it but he wants us to be perfect and
i really appreciate that yeah i do my
part where i can for sure and the love
appears to be mutual last month tom was
one of the first people to wish zendaya
a happy birthday posting this sweet snap
to instagram and judging by the spidey
suit it looks like a throwback of the
stars in the hair and makeup trailer
while they were filming the superhero
flick but it was the british star's
caption that had fans gushing quote my
mj have the happiest of birthdays give
me a call when you're up xxx and just a
few weeks before that the pair was
photographed showing off some pda in
july they were spotted kissing in a car
i am sweating a source told et at the
time that the duo celebrated the 4th of
july together with a getaway to santa
barbara enjoying a weekend of casual
dining hanging poolside and even a round
of mini-golf around the same time they
even attended a wedding together of
course neither zendaya nor tom has
confirmed a relationship but the
euphoria star has opened up about dating
in the public eye it's just hard to date
in general you know sometimes it's hard
to you know find people that you really
click with or really understand you and
and add on top of the fact that my
lifestyle is very different so i mean
it's just tough but i'm jealous romance
rumors between the actors first began in
2017 during the worldwide press tour for
spider-man homecoming hey where you
going
what are you hiding peter
i'm just kidding i don't care bye have
you found that it's hard to date in
hollywood that's such a young age of
course it is i mean it's hard today at
any age i mean it doesn't matter you
know where you are either i mean it's
just hard to say in general at the time
zendaya shut down speculation she and
tom are more than friends telling
variety that he's simply one of her best
friends and quote a great dude and that
august the dune star told et
none of that romance chatter has faced
her this happens all the time and of
course you know we we expected it i mean
it's um
it comes with the territory it comes
with the job so it's all good